what do you think it is about giving
something a couple decades and letting
it breathe and then it's as all of a
sudden this yeah this classic or this
rare gem yeah what is that seems that
seems to happen yeah I don't know what
it is I don't know if it's just that
certain films are ahead of their time or
that you know the public isn't ready to
embrace it at the time it's made but
then suddenly the general audience
catches up you know with what that thing
is and you know you see it all the time
now you see it constantly films that
we're absolute disasters are now looked
upon as classics and even heaven's gate
has been you know reevaluated or one of
my favorite films sorcerer which is
William freaking remake of wages of fear
which is you know enormous adventure
dark adventure film that he made in 1977
which by took 22 studios to finance and
it just died at the box office is now in
the last couple of years being regarded
as a as a classic to be reconsidered so
I think the thing has always been though
that the difference between the movie
like ad will Atwoods films versus even
Heaven's Gate or certainly source or
anything you can think of that's been
rediscovered is that the movies tend to
be good you know and it's just there
looked upon their looked upon as being
rediscovered because at the time they
didn't make money but I think that's the
thing that most of us should really bear
in mind always is that how much
something earns should not be weighted
with its aesthetic value I mean value
such a weird term it's like people this
for years and years and years ever since
Entertainment Tonight came on television
box office was made public have equated
good with how much money it's made you
know but I've always said that by that
by that standard you know Two and a Half
Men or whatever you know sitcom of the
week that's maquette 80 Jillian viewers
is the greatest piece of art ever made
so and all you had to do is look at
anything you know like that's why I love
duck have you ever see the beginning of
Robert Altman's movie Vincent and Theo
is a great sort of way of encapsulating
what that means because the way Vincent
and Theo opens which is about Vincent
mango and as a relationship with his
brother is it starts with a real like
Christie's or Sotheby's auction of
sunflowers whenever that was in the 70s
or whatever it just starts with the
auction video and they're saying do I
hear 20 million dollars or 25 million
dose I have 25 million do I have 30
million SOI valiant negozi and as this
millions are being offered for
sunflowers there's this long dissolve to
van Gogh played by tim roth like
freezing to death in his Shack in the
winter and he's got no teeth and he's
suffering from lead poisoning and he's
completely unappreciated like you know
and that's the whole thing with van Gogh
and yes all of us would like to say yes
I am then go and nobody appreciates but
I'm not saying that but I'm saying there
was a whether it's timing or you know
whether van Gogh's work with I'm sure
there are millions of scholars that have
already said y vengo was not as
successful but it's something about I
think the general public is not want
something a certain way look at punk
rock I mean this is crazy like like my
wife you know was a punk rocker in the
80s and she always talks about how you
know you couldn't people spit on her
yeah for looking that way you know
people spit on her that things like hair
dye like you couldn't just go get Manic
Panic down at the store if you wanted
your hair green or blue I get you know
paint your hair and like that was a
political statement that people were not
ready for at all you know the cops would
hassle you people were just like you
were disgusting and now you know seven
year old girls girls go to school and
would be addressed in that same thing so
lipstick yeah and now that's all you
know something as simple as like oh
she's got green hair is just like you
know that is nothing that doesn't mean
that has no there's not offensive at all
it doesn't if anything it's just banal
whereas you know 20 years earlier 30
years earlier you would have been you
know and now you know the same thing you
know anything political is that way gay
marriage you know 20 years from now
people going to say how the hell
why is that not you know legal you know
so I think the public whatever you want
to call it we certainly represents the
audience's that judge whether a movie is
successful tend to be slow to getting it
and I don't know what that is I don't
know I don't know I don't know there
certainly if you're a radical thinker or
an alternative thinker then you're going
to be more inclined to appreciate
something left of center when it comes
out but that's not how things are judged
things are judged by how the most number
of people either liked it or they didn't
like it and the most number of people
are net aren't necessarily the best
judge of whether something is good it's
just what they're ready for you know
you